Dirty joke,
in Ernst,
Lubitsch masterpiece Ninotchka the hero
visits a cafeteria and orders coffee
without cream,
and here is the wonderful lip reply of
the waiter.
Sorry,
we have run out of cream.
We only have milk.
Can I then bring you coffee without
milk?
I think it's absolutely a correct
answer.
It's not the same thing.
Coffee without cream or coffee without
milk.
What you don't get,
it's part of the identity of what you do
get in what sense?
Because if you bring this logic to its
extreme,
you can also see how a double negation
when you don't have just when you do not
have,
in this case,
coffee without cream or milk.
The result is not zero,
but what another.
My last example from popular culture
from,
I think it's from early nineties,
you remember the movie with Ethan
Mcgregor before he became a trader when
he was still playing a working class.
Guys brassed off the hero accompanies,
took her home after their date.
A young pretty woman who at the entrance
to her flat tells Kim,
would you like to come in for a coffee?
He answers there is a problem.
I don't drink,
drink,
drink coffee.
She retorts with a smile.
No problem.
I don't have any.
What I like is that you know what?
You get through this.
Double negation is probably the most,
not vulgar,
but open erotic invitation.
Like that's my point.
I invite you for a coffee.
Then I negate coffee and the result is
not zero.
The result is beautiful invitation.